[Musica]
no
però nascosto qualcosa qui a vita per i
qualcosa da mangiare
controlliamo ma chi è
sembra nita sembra stia facendo yoga
sì sì sembra proprio una posizione di
yoga
forse è meglio se vado a controllare
[Musica]
sfida
ma che cosa sta facendo
vita
tutto bene sembri bloccata fin disturbo
se per caso facendo yoga
adesso vi vado a mangiare tutto quello
che trova
ma questo è un po preoccupante sta
tornando a vinta svegliati o no che le è
successo venuta un'idea davvero prendere
qualcosa per sbloccarla aspettate qui è
[Musica]
la mia idea e consiste in questo
rastrelli gli spaventapasseri mi sa che
hanno paura dei rastrelli no ecco fatto
che grande artista non mi sembra molto
contenta però adesso provo ad abbassare
quelle braccia deve essere molto scomodo
immagino un occhio
insomma effettivamente è colpa mia
dovevo prima rimuovere il castello
[Applauso]
si sta muovendo sembra non funziona
forse sta giocando con due tre stella
giochiamo un destra stella forse quello
è ok allora il reggino e 23 non si è
mossa
allora forse è meglio se mi allontano
estera non funziona
su 22 o si sta avvicinando due tre
stalla
ma si è mossa
1236 volta l'ho beccato si è mossa dopo
di nuovo possibile si è girata ok
[Musica]
dopo mi stava per beccare un bastone
questo è molto strano sta bene provo 23
per cento scappata per scappare poco
aiuto profilo aiutami
che cosa sta succedendo
che cosa è successo e perché le si
bloccava mi stai vincere ed utile un
attimo fa ho capito la fanno le
cornacchie che la bloccano allora niente
neanche con il verso delle cornacchie
riesco a sbloccarla
magari la porta dentro casa se la portò
in cameretta magari si ricorderà che in
realtà non è uno spaventapasseri mai
anita magari così si sbloccherà questa
madre edizione no vediamo prova a
portarla
[Musica]
ok allora abbassiamo queste braccia e mi
hanno ancora bloccata guardati intorno
vedi qui è dove facciamo i video
preferita stories ti ricordi stessa è
venuta degli altri ma solo una cosa
ecco questo è tuo
il to play button 6 video su youtube è
la vita stories guarda c'è scritto pure
ma guarda o giovedì la vita stories
ricordi ricordi qualcosa no se è citata
solo stranamente come prima devo trovare
un'altra soluzione
così non sembra proprio funzionare
pensiamo pensiamo a tutto sono lenta
passeri spaventapasseri quindi ho capito
che le cornacchie bloccano lo
spaventapasseri
sì ci sono però di che cosa hanno paura
gli spaventapasseri fanno paura
seganti forse hanno paura dei gatti non
possono magari aver paura tv e ci sono
paure del fuoco adesso prende bel popolo
eletto quasi certo di no forse poco un
po esagerato è però punterei trovare una
soluzione simile ma differente aspettate
qui a ecco qui ho portato il fuoco o
meglio ho portato la candela e
l'accendino per fare il fuoco quindi
proviamo ad accendere la candela chi
candela accesa vedete mettiamo
sembra funzionare
si sta pigiando capitato
buongiorno è che ho appena salvata una
cosa è bloccata se vi presento uno
spaventapasseri cemento su questo me li
metto tutta in oro che ho messo io ti ho
detto che stavi facendo lo
spaventapasseri perché è una candela
profumata in mano
non sapevo come sbloccarti mi è venuto
in mente che forse gli spaventapasseri
hanno paura del fuoco quindi io lasciato
una candela per noi per portare un fuoco
il tema poi davvero è sì un po
complicato infatti spiega perché cosa è
successo dimmi tu che cosa è successo
perché lei vestita da spaventapasseri ma
non chiamo vestita io lo spaventapasseri
e non lo so stiene voluto io ti ho visto
da qui che stavi da fuori e sono andato
a vedere che cosa stava succedendo e poi
dopo un po praticamente un po di cose
mirato contrastare il mio intento del
dovuto scappare ti ho preso che portato
che aveva complicato adesso sono troppe
scioccato per spiegare come sempre le
tre spiegazioni non hanno nessun senso
beppe più stretta hai detto spaventa
pasti disegni il porto dello
spaventapasseri l'hai visto
no ho visto the prestito da
spaventapasseri macché
meno male no non so nessuno
spaventapasseri stavo scherzando non c'è
nessuno spaventapasseri e fornaci e ora
come reagirà tutti
no
[Musica]